-Making her TV debut, performing
her global hit "abcdefu,"
give it up for Gayle!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I swear I meant to mean
the best when it ended ♪
♪ Even tried to bite my tongue
when you start ♪
♪ Now you're textin' all my
friends, asking questions ♪
♪ They never even liked you
in the first place ♪
♪ Dated a girl
that I hate for the attention ♪
♪ She only made it two days,
what a connection ♪
♪ Like you'd do anything
for my affection ♪
♪ You're goin' all about it
in the worst ways ♪
♪ I was into you
but I'm over it now ♪
♪ And I was tryin' to be nice ♪
♪ Nothing's getting through ♪
♪ Let me spell it out ♪
♪ A-B-C-D-E ♪
♪ Forget you and your mom
and your sister ♪
♪ And your job
and your broke-down car ♪
♪ And the things you call art ♪
♪ Forget you and your friends
that I'll never see again ♪
♪ Everybody but your dog,
you can all get lost ♪
♪ Nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah ♪
♪ A-B-C-D-E, forget you ♪
♪ You said you just needed space
and so I gave it ♪
♪ I have nothin' to say,
you couldn't take it ♪
♪ Told everyone I'm a ♪
♪ So I became it ♪
♪ Always had to put yourself
above me ♪
♪ I was into you
but I'm over it now ♪
♪ And I was tryin' to be nice ♪
♪ Nothing's getting through ♪
♪ Let me spell it out ♪
♪ A-B-C-D-E ♪
♪ Forget you and your mom
and your sister ♪
♪ And your job
and your Craigslist couch ♪
♪ And the way
your voice sounds ♪
♪ Forget you and your friends
that I'll never see again ♪
♪ Everybody but your dog,
you can all get loooost ♪
♪ Nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah ♪
♪ A-B-C-D-E, forget you ♪
♪ Nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah ♪
♪ A-B-C-D-E ♪
♪ Forget you and your mom
and your sister ♪
♪ And your job
and your broke-down car ♪
♪ Things you call art ♪
♪ Forget you and your friends
that I'll never see again ♪
♪ Everybody but your dog,
you can all get lost ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]